qui déjà ne sais pas moi je vois à peu
près qui vous êtes mais cette annonce
n'a pas fait taire vision lancé mardi
son indice en voilà tiers des sommets
bien vu l'hôtel du temps je suis à dix
ans j'ai rendez vous là à que de temps
perdu à gagner du temps monsieur
ardisson prenez votre temps ici les
seconds dur des siècles
[Musique]
oui
thierry ardisson a rendez vous avec jean
gabin il a ressuscité la grande gueule
du cinéma français à grand renfort de
technologie il en a profité pour se
refaire la gueule à lui à l'écran il
s'est rajeuni de vingt ans thierry
ardisson joue avec le temps des stars du
passé des images du futur un animateur
de maintenant thierry ardisson en dorian
gray de la télévision l'institut
national des archives lui consacre un
canal à part entière sur youtube ça
s'appelle hardy tube tout le monde en
parle paris dernière il droite rive
gauche bain de minuit lunettes noires
pour nuits blanches etc des centaines
d'heures de télé sélectionné découper
éditorialisé est présenté par le
ardisson de maintenant racontant le
ardisson d'antan pour qui est bien pour
les générations de demain assurément
l'homme en noir tend un miracle rendre
l'éphémère de toute éternité ardisson
joue avec le temps ardisson joue avec la
mort évidemment l'instant
sony de villers
sur france inter j'ai pas au mauvais
caractère j'ai du caractère c'est tout
alors forcément tu comprends quand on a
du caractère il est toujours mauvais
pour les autres à ce qu'on fait parce
qu'ils veulent un
cette idée thierry ardisson bonjour j'ai
trouvé totalement farfelue et maintenant
que jean paul belmondo est mort je me
disais mais si samedi soir il y avait
jean paul belmondo façade en train de
répondre à une interview façon je ne
sais pas quoi façon thierry ardisson se
serait hyper émouvant bien entendu là
c'est un peu frais même parce qu'on est
tous bouleversés évidemment par la mort
de l'immense belmondo mais j'espère
effectivement dans l'avenir avoir la
chance de faire un hôtel du temps avec
avec belmondo et soul et quand vous
dites une interview dans l'émission ils
ne disent que des choses qu'ils ont
vraiment dit ça c'est très important je
crois que c'est ce qui est le plus
important c'est que les gens comprennent
bien que je suis pas en train de faire
parler jean gabin les gilet jaune
belmondo du procès de novembre c'est à
dire qu'en fait il que c'est très
compliqué à préparer d'ailleurs parce
qu'on s'est un peu comme jeopardy on a
les réponses et on fait les questions
après il faut trouver un ton quand même
conversationnel
alors qu'en face de moi j'avais un
comédien excellent d'ailleurs s'appelle
cédric weber
le mette dans la tête que c'était gabin
qu'il aurait au final la tête de gamin
et quand il ya une séquence sur le toit
de l'hôtel du temps avec le soleil qui
se couche et gabin qui parle de sa main
et pourtant c'était cédric weber et ben
je suis fille j'ai fondu en larmes ouais
cette séquence parce que moi je pensais
que le résultat serait un peu sinistre
un peu crépusculaire en réalité c'est
très beau tout ça c'est une grande
prouesse technologique les schémas
gaffard il faut les féliciter une
fistule et merci d'abord de l'intérêt
que vous y porter parce que je crois que
c'est très important oui ça arrive en
gros après noël oui oui c'est ça c'est
ça parce que la france télévisions a vu
gabin ils ont beau coupé mais ils m'ont
dit écoute on voudrait commencer par
quelqu'un de peut-être plus fort j'irai
- service public c'est horrible mais
quelqu'un qui fasse plus d'audience
comme satan émissions commenceraient
voilà non mais c'est bien c'est gentil
en même temps c'est bien des noms je
crois qu'il faut quand même remercier
d'abord
delphine ernotte c'est à dire que la
première fois que je suis allée la voir
avec cette idée en novembre 2019 elle
m'a dit oui thierry donc ça c'est
extraordinaire parce que vous pouvez
voir toutes les bonnes idées du monde si
vous n'avez personne pour vous les
achetez vous en faites rien et puis
aussi il faut citer mac guff carnet de
prouesses techniques c'est une boîte
extraordinaire il connaissait pas du
tout ce procédé ici sont mis j'étais
obligé à 6 mètres et maintenant ils sont
devenus fréquents en france on est en
avance pour une fois cocorico c'est à
dire que l'émission n'existe pas
ailleurs évidemment on l'a vendu en
espagne en italie en allemagne en
discuter
typiquement concept que vous allez
vendre à l'interdire ce qu'il faut dire
quand même c'est pour ça il faut être
vraiment se dire on a un truc on a
inventé un truc parce que alors
je vous dise a pu apprendre à d'autres
choses j'ai lu de 2,3 papier un peu
dubitatif je vois que quand on a vu
l'émission on est plus dubitatif on
comprend ma démarche qui est une
démarche de transmission j'étais
extrêmement respectueux et les héritiers
de gabin parce que je suis allé les voir
je redis voilà je vais faire c'est avec
votre père je vous montrerai le scénario
je la vois ressuscité dalida voilà c'est
chaque fois j'ai vu j'ai vu aussi les
héritiers donc ça c'est très important
la deuxième chose que la presse veut
mais il faut dire une chose c'est que ce
procédé là c'est un outil est comme un
marteau de dire un marteau pour taper
sur un cloud pour taper sur une tête si
vous faites du dip fait que j'appelle ça
des faits stricte rigueur parce que
c'est plus sophistiqués techniquement
que y si vous faites ça passe on vous
mettez emmanuel macron à poil sur une
plage ça c'est néfaste fait mauvais
c'est pas bien si vous mettez comme bien
sûr youtube hitler et staline qui chante
du ah bah ça peut être comique moi je
suis ni dans des fast né dans le comics
je suis dans le temps dans cette idée
d'un d'un d'utiliser la technologie cet
outil technologique pour être positif
pour être culturel pour transmettre
voilà j'ai pour transmettre et pour
travailler sur les archives on va en
parler ce matin avec des argentières dit
si vous êtes dans un grand travail
d'archivage l'auteur chival je veux leur
audition avant de mourir je mets en
ambre même quelque chose comme ça fait
j'ai retrouvé sur hardy tube la chaîne
que vous consacre l'ina j'ai retrouvé
des extraits absolument géniaux deux de
ces dîners cathodique que vous
organisiez chez vous ou rue du
faubourg-saint-honoré là vous avez
invité à dîner michel drucker nikos
aliagas bruno gaccio écouter frédéric
taddeï se demander qu'est ce qui va
rester au fond du cinéma mais aussi des
gens de télévision au départ qui étaient
les stars c'était des gens qui avaient
accompli de véritable exploit ensuite le
cinéma inventé les stars qui me met les
exploitent ce qui les avait vraiment que
les pâtes et enfin c'était quand même
des surhommes c'est quand même des mecs
qui nous impressionnait mais il ne
faisait qu'un carnet l'exploit que
d'autres avaient commis après on est
descendu d'un cran avec la télévision il
y en ait eu michel drucker ou jean
pierre foucault qui sont monsieur tout
le monde c'est à dire il nous ressemble
et ensuite arrive la télé réalité est là
tout à coup on prend comme star des gens
qui sont en gros on va dire c'est
l'idiot dû village c'est à dire celles
inférieures
thierry ardisson quand on met ses
affaires en ordre quand on met ses
archives en ordre canton mais l'histoire
de la télévision en ordre on se pose
forcément la question de qu'est-ce qu'on
garde et qu'est-ce qu'on jette qu'est ce
qui reste et qu'est-ce qui passe alors
moi j'ai une façon de faire de la télé
qui ai je dit pas différente mais enfin
disons qu'il est très particulière c'est
que je fais sérieusement des choses
superficielles dire que quand je faisais
mes interviews je l'écrivais je la
tourne et je la monte et je la mixer ce
qui fait que ça donne une pérennité aux
interviews c'est pas juste comme s'ils
jouaient tout le temps la télé ans mon
salut comment tu vas pas du tout moi
c'est l inverse de sa souvent c'était
vous êtes né à at-elle années et ça
c'est très didactique déjà au départ
donc j'ai pas eu de problème de
sélection parce que finalement il n'y
avait pas des mauvaises interview parce
que ce qui était mauvais dans
l'interview avait été coupée au montage
donc si vous voulez j'ai pas eu le choix
après l'idée c'était de les classer
d'une façon précise que les gens soient
pas devant masse d'image qu'il y était
très très quand même sur la spécialité
tirée à 10 ans a toujours été mélangés
tard je suis la notion de sarrab
beaucoup changé dans ces années vous
avez fait de la télévision et des et des
anonymes et donc ce qui est extrêmement
intéressant quand on regarde vos
archives c'est que parfois on se dit
l'animateur reste c'est vous
l'émission reste c'est tout le monde en
parle mais la star enfin on sait pas
très bien quel statut lui donnez vous
interviewez à l'époque elle l a
complètement disparu écoutez marjolaine
qui venait tout le temps chez vous
aujourd'hui on ne sait même plus qui
heureusement
pour me séduire il faut être sincère
honnête et pas ici de maculer
est-ce qu'une fois qu'on vous a séduit
ça peut se discuter après
on rigolait bien tout les cas on
rigolait bien mais c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est de se dire finalement
il ya des invités qui vieillissent plus
vite que l'émission elle-même vous dites
la télé c'est éphémère mais en réalité
la télé parfois la des dispositifs qui
restent et les gens passent oui mais la
télé c'est éphémère parce
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui que
reste-t-il moi je vous la fois que
j'étais ici et je l'en remercie encore
c'était pour un documentaire sur le rtf
et justement ça prouve enfin le
documentaire prouver ce que vous dites
c'est à dire que les gens aujourd'hui
ils se souviennent plus de daisy
gallardo jean christophe averty de
denise glaser et encore moins des gens
qui étaient invités chez eux alors
maintenant ce que je voudrais dire au
sujet de la chaîne youtube très
important là c'est pareil comme delphine
ernotte faut quand même rendre hommage
aux gens qui vous ont fait confiance je
voudrais remercier leur emballé le
patron de l'ina ina que vous pouvez
recevoir qui est un type vraiment
marrant mais vraiment sympa et lui m'a
quand même donc on avait fait ainsi
faire ma propre nom vous avez invité que
des grands patrons remerciés qui voulait
renvoyer des ascenseurs et auprès des
trucs beaucoup plus fun que vous non
mais c'est vrai que quand même ils m'ont
donné cette chance ya dix ans de faire
un site avec toutes mes interviews dix
ans après il m'appelle et me dit alors
en hindi écouter ce que tu voudrais
faire une chaîne youtube ah oui et
légumes où je dire c'est génial parce
que enfin je sais pas mais quand on est
animateur de télé on pense qu'on a perdu
sa vie en fait et puis on s'aperçoit
quand même qu'à d'autres trucs pas mal
quoi donc voilà ces récompenses ont
quand même un qui li na a proposé ça
cheuvreux coeur téléphone tous les jours
à linars mais c'est toujours pas fait
la télé adorent recycler sa propre
matière et se regarder dans le miroir on
a vu le succès cela la saison dernière
détiennent carbonnier qui est le gamin
qui bosse dans le quotidien et kike qui
en a fait des ddd soirée des prêts mais
ça a cartonné
il ya notamment un prisme autour de la
télé
années 90 qu'est ce qui marche encore
dans cette télé là pour le pour le
spectateur de genre d'une marche si vous
laissez que aujourd'hui il faut dire les
choses sinon je serais toujours en train
de farrou tokyo je veux dire quand
j'étais viré par bolo rei à d'autres
chaînes qui m'ont appelé j'aurais pu
aller faire un ton joyeux le problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya plus de stars
c'est à dire que gainsbourg est mort
quoi pour résumer les stars qui restent
elles vont pas la télé parce qu'elle
trouve ça pas chic c'est avant la télé
vous appelez quelqu'un était déjà au
maquillage maintenant c'est moins chic
donc par exemple ils font des 20 heures
ça c'est très chic le 20 heures du
dimanche soir sur tf1 ce formidable ils
vont plus à lattes et donc à plus de
stars et celles qui viennent à la télé
et les stars qu'ils elles veulent pas
parler parce qu'elles ont peur des
réseaux sociaux donc ce qui fait que
c'est fini
le talk show et que le vrai oxo
évidemment pas toujours faire de la
promo en disant votre film est
formidable c'est à dire en a tous les
jours mais le vrai hawk show incisif
impertinent banques comme vous venez de
le dire ne peut plus exister parce que
il n'ya plus la matière et deux sites
antiques et la maintien ils ont peur ils
sont terrorisés moi je me souviens je
raconte cette anecdote quand même un
jour je reçois à la fin de ces huit je
reçois franck dubosc s'est vite c'était
salut les terriens
les terriens arrive sur la chaîne
youtube vous venez juste de 2,2 de
négocier sur l'arrivée de ses archives à
ça c'est formidable ce qu'il ya toutes
les émissions de tf1 france 2 paris
première canal à ses 8 qui était la fin
la fin mai terrain et donc l'attaché de
presse me dit j'espère que tu vas pas
lui parler des gilet jaune j'ai dit ah
ben pourquoi non écoute soit gentil
donne à voir une histoire classique des
jaunes franck faut pas déconner
franquart et devinez pourquoi votre
tâche qu'il presse ne dit pas vous
parler des îles et jaune la fille vient
voir la fin des missions elle me dit bon
match a bien compris tu l'auras plus
jamais donc ça veut dire que maintenant
tout est beaucoup négocié d' avance avec
les attachés de presse vous parlez de ça
vous parlez de ça on parlait pas de ça
une fois qu'ils sont là ils sont
terrorisés par les réseaux sociaux donc
le métier mort je vous dis tout de suite
le métier le vrai toxo encore une fois
après un vrai on peut faire de la
promotion mais par exemple ce qui
m'impressionne c'est que depuis quelques
mois sur tik tok est vraiment le réseau
le plus jeune de tous les réseaux
sociaux est bas les gamins s'échangent
des dizaines de vidéos d'extrait de
bataille et fontaine c'est quand même
et par ailleurs et c'est un peu ce trop
si c'est cher
et par ailleurs il ya on s'est demandé
aussi avec l'équipe de l'instant même
qu'est ce qui restait de la télévision
qu est-ce qui vieillissent et moi alors
c'est sûr que les marjolaine et autres
starlettes éphémère elle elle
disparaisse complètement et en même
temps se disent qu'ils ce qui marche le
mieux ce qui vit le mieux c'est la
télévision de témoignages vous vous en
avez recueilli beaucoup des témoignages
il ya un extrait c'était un type qui
s'appelle jessica raconté son enfance ça
revient non-stop sur les réseaux sociaux
tout le temps au quotidien j'avais des
maltraitances
le classique c'était le martinet
l'accord en mettant à genoux sur une
grille un paillasson métalliques ça fait
super mal
le métal sur le genou la sensation avec
les mains sur la tête c'est horrible et
ça ça revient tout le temps ça ça
vieillit cela s'est jamais date et je
vais vous dire une chose la télévision
peut être très négatif pour un animateur
elle peut vous enfermer dans une espèce
de tour d'ivoire et puis vous commencez
à regarder les gens de haut et puis vous
vous prenez pour ce que vous n'êtes pas
mens pas vous prenez pour une star et un
mois la télévision moi j'étais très
bonne car yves et moi quand j'ai
commencé la télé j'étais pas bien
j'étais boucle et la télévision m'a
obligé à m'intéresser aux autres
qu'incroyable j'étais payé pour
m'intéresser par exemple à jesse donc
jeté payer pour m'intéresser aux gens et
je travaille sur coluche en ce moment
est connu c'est pourquoi elle dit en
protégeant les coluche quand il était
quand il était jeune il détestait la
terre entière était très célinien
coluche en fait ils trouvaient que les
ports été condamné c'est pts et leur
condition de pauvre voilà et à force de
parler avec les gens à la radio at et à
europe 1 quand il parlait d'après midi
avec des gens qui racontaient leur
malheur la radio moi c'est la télé lui
c'est la radio la radio la rapprocher
des gens il a terminé en 5e luche quoi
les restos du coeur les pionniers enfin
tout ça c'est à dire que c'est pour ça
que ce jeu ça m'intéresse beaucoup de
films de travailler sur lui parce que
c'est un peu le même phénomène c'est à
dire que la télé au lieu de nous isoler
du monde nous a rapprochées du monde je
dirais pas que la radio a humanisé
coluche faisait déjà très humaniste mais
il était de moins en moins ses lignes et
en plus sur hardy tube j'ai retrouvé pas
mal d'archivés des choses qui m'ont
totalement étonné
vous par exemple en train de dire de
quelle classe sociale doit être issu un
animateur télé et justement ça c'est
exactement ce que vous venez de raconter
c'est vrai que la plupart des animateurs
qui ont réussi la télé ils sont des gens
qui sont issus de la petite bourgeoisie
d'attenté quand tu viens d'une classe
sociale trop élevé tu n'as pas le
contact avec les gens et quand tu as une
classe sociale trop toulousaine pour
l'été ria t'as pas le contact entre eux
oui c'est ça c'est à dire que la
télévision comme triomphe de la petite
bourgeoisie oui parce que les gens qu'il
est en fait eu une interview ça se passe
entre cadieux comme je le dis dans le
parisien en parlant de ruquier c'est
qu'en fait si vous voulez il faut voir
le contact avec les gens si vous avez
été élevé dans une vraiment dans une
classe sociale fait l écho la jambe et
vous avez fréquenté des rallyes
bousteila au golf avec papa c'est pas
possible ce qui n'est pas l'histoire de
rue thiers nancy classe autour d'henri
cuq c'était sur l'histoire faut-il
interviewé à 2 oui voilà mais c'est une
autre question mais si vous voulez
et que si vous venez du lumpen
prolétariat vous n'avez pas les codes
c'est pas la culture générale c'est
souvent ce qui se passe avec l'animateur
aujourd'hui c'est on voit bien qu'ils
n'ont pas de culture générale et s'ils
voulaient c'est très compliqué comme
vous n'avez pas de culture générale de
vous de faire parler quelqu'un qui a
priori en a plus que vous donc la petite
la petite bourgeoisie qui est allé à
l'école c'est formidable en 1986 vous
n'étiez pas encore une star de télé vous
étiez un pubard vous veniez de sortir un
livre sur l'histoire des bourbons et sur
votre vocation monarchie vous étiez
invité chez pivot vous portiez à
l'époque un costard beige et un polo
bordeaux je regrette c'est peut-être la
dernière choix regrette tout est ce que
vous disiez regarder en 80 président
mitterrand fait une affiche la force
tranquille
le petit clocher le ciel bleu blanc
rouge enfin tout ça c'était un peu
pétainiste in séguéla s'essayer laquelle
ces sacs et là qu'il a fait ah bon il
était pétainiste dont la fiche est un
peu pessimiste alors moi je me dis que
dans l'avenir si on a de l'argent et une
bonne agence tout le monde peut se faire
élire président de la république surtout
que maintenant que c'est au suffrage
universel je suis inquiet pour la
démocratie réellement j'ai peur j'ai
peur qu'on ait la naissance d'une espèce
de petit l'ère médiatique comme ça
ils sont nés les petits de l'ère
médiatique de bord tiges ardisson disant
coup et disons que on voit bien les
élections et a pas en france encore ça
se passe encore à peu près bien mais
enfin quand vous voyez bolton en eau par
exemple qu'on meilleur ban
quand vous voyez le le turc erdogan on
voit bien qu'on assiste à la naissance
de petits claire médiatique de
absolument pas ce que
je sais plus dans quel bel s'est laissée
il vous interdise info quoi un moment
donc on est bien et ils se vendent
vous reviendrez pour nous parler de tels
du même nom des copains la première fois
c'était un peu chaud vous aviez non mais
je vais vous dire une chose non mais je
vais vous dire un truc sonia
qu'honnêtement way la première fois que
je suis venu vous m'avez dit en gros un
mec comme vous avec tout ce que vous
avez fait vous retrouver sur ces huit en
train d'interviewer chez pas qui non
seulement ça me déçoit pas vrai mais
c'est comme ça que je les
tue tour vous veniez de produire une
série qui s'appelait péplum sur m6 et je
la trouvais pas bonne du tout a marché
mais leurs productions et je me disais
un mec qui a toujours revendiqué la
culture à la télévision le
divertissement de qualité etc il
pourrait faire mieux que ça je vous ai
écoutés là je reviens à côté du temps
merci
hardy tubes et donc on arnaque c'est
évidemment pour tout le monde gratuit
sur youtube et c'est signé li na et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater le lit nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou